[Music]
in fake facts news I love they tell me
to always what to say that I'm all that
is submitted by Orchestral Manoeuvres in
the dark what I might do is I'm gonna
give Tyco up a bunch of fake facts and
hopefully he's smart enough to figure it
out what's real and what's fake
that was our childhood all right uh the
widely cited Stanford Prison Experiment
has been exposed as fraudulent what does
this really tell David what it is you
could we were going over just whisper it
suppose I want David to be out of the
circle and it's not one no I don't know
a lot of things you know more do you
know so we can't roast ambo he can make
him like feel not included what I can
look it up on Google later but I would
like to know now you know this one you
just don't know the name of it you know
about that experiment when they were
forced to press a button and it [ __ ]
hurts them Oh which one is the ceremony
I never held the [ __ ] story hmm
okay you took psychology you learn this
[ __ ] I did take psychology emotional
psychology mmm-hmm I didn't so this is
the first time I heard of it so I'm with
you I just balance the pH I'm about it
all right thanks for the alkalized all
right so it turns out that okay so yeah
that that's whole experiment is one of
the most famous and compelling
psychological studies of all time and
has been included in many intro
psychology textbooks it's the subject of
movies documentaries books television
shows and well tell them what the
experiment is like how do you do it how
did the experiment happen on the trains
and they're like are you gonna kill him
or not oh that's a good one too though
we don't actually have it does this
smell like fried chicken in here mm-hmm
what is going on people we thought my
food every episode okay what the ones
that David did
so this study one of the paid
participants and assign them to be
inmates or guards in this mock prison Oh
at Stanford University and so it turns
out that the guards began mistreating
the prisoners implying that evil is
brought out by circumstance and it
concluded that in conclusion it
suggested that innocent people thrown
into a situation where they have power
over others will abuse that power and so
they're saying that the people who are
put into a situation where they are
powerless will be driven to submission
even madness so that's what it concluded
but it turned out to be false
ah because there's this expose that
medium.com published and they found that
a lot of previously unpublished
recordings of Philip Zimbardo which is a
psychologist who ran this study they
they also interviewed a lot of people
that had participated in the original
study and in in the recorded interviews
they were saying that participants were
convinced that evidence of the guards in
the experiment were coached to be cruel
it was biased from the start they were
saying that like for example there was
this one prisoner who went into a
screaming fit proclaiming I'm burning up
inside but that was just the prisoner
acting and then the prison one of the
prison guards said that he took that as
an improv exercise and he believed that
he was doing what the researchers wanted
him to do oh so it wasn't even why did
it take so long for it to come out now
like wouldn't people like you two
bunking it like forever ago well
apparently a lot of like they have been
saying that a lot of these psychological
the classic psychological experience
they're not the example size was too
small or like whoever was running the
experiment would coach people to have
like a bias approach to it and so now
they're they're just a whole bunch of
psychology
that means all the [ __ ] that I [ __ ]
learn is lies
just one thing [ __ ] man up it's a lot of
experience a lot of [ __ ] that's a kind
of a well-known thing in statistics now
I'm like a really busy SATs nerd is that
like a study will come out and then
everybody public like make like makes
all the articles public and then they're
like okay let's do this again and then
it changes a little bit and then they're
like okay let's do this again and
they're like okay well these this is
actually how it should come out it's
almost always bias in the beginning it
what's so annoying like stats are
supposed to be definitively objective
you know I mean and now I it's not
they're all subjective now so you'll
have like like political debates will to
bring ups Tesla Oh what your status is
that well get sucka mice test is the
opposite [ __ ] poll they think it's a
fact yes because it comes out like they
put on actual journals that are those
like 20 pages long journals and nobody
wants to read those so that news
reporters go in and they pull out
headlines and then that's the second
part and then the third part is the
public's interpretation like so all
stacks are Jack the the he is the gay
Republican Christian or Catholic was his
name noxious a statistic say like what
are those it's like well what what stats
are you talking about or the this
another guy named Stephen crowd ego
states this is like what was gonna read
the whole article
I love debunking statistics they do this
all the time in advertisement right like
they'll be like oh well this has
antioxidants or chocolate does this or
whatever and then you look at it there's
that little asterisk next to it it is
half true it's true enough to where they
could advertise it but it's like oh well
in order for chocolate to have these
health benefits you need to consume like
a gallon of it or whatever you know like
or like they don't tell you the other
dark side of the truth where it's like
if you consume that much candy bars
there's so much sugar and you know so I
don't know it's just all these I can't
trust nothing yeah because they think
that we're stupid and it is true though
the public is not educated enough to
debunk certain statistics yeah and
that's why there does mm-hmm we are all
done
then it all depends on definitions -
there's oblate all our beef has never
been frozen and you asked or you look
into what the definition have never been
frozen and don't consider like if
anything hasn't been frozen for over 24
hours it's considered never frozen
yeah but that's actually the minute the
minute you put in a freezer it's frozen
or even when there's the product says
like cruelty free it's a it's like we
only hit that chicken once oh we don't
classify rats as being considered an
animal okay here's the perfect example
of the biggest lie as a child when I was
a teenager I dyed my hair black because
they said permanent hair color and they
just meant six months because it's the
most permanent out there on the market I
was like this is a lie I thought my hair
was gonna be black forever that's what
those sharpies were actual hair isn't
black this is like dark brown baby oh
yeah she's like a number two around
there
thank you David he's black just solitude
that's all about the definition [ __ ]
degrees useless I mean it is right you
don't use it my degree is useless tuto a
little bit what marketing marketing is
not useless uh I was just trying to make
you feel good I guess I meant like the
tangible degree is I've been taught a
lie
marketing still worked I don't know a
month or so ago would you tell me she's
like I got a business degree and I said
I'm in the presence of a strong [ __ ]
got a psychology degree and I thought I
knew people but I don't know [ __ ] I
dropped out what were you gonna major in
I was a double in education and social
and then I had like a bunch of minors
just because I just fell we had the
similar type of useless degrees I really
wasn't gonna do much with it it's the
liberal [ __ ] the liberal arts you had a
double major all these - that's just
because I wasn't called forever yeah I
mean so I just kept taking class
and they all just kind of linked up and
so I could just you know fill all the
requirements with each other doesn't
mean I'm smart just means I'm dumb
yeah I get a minor to an econ just with
one more class I'm like [ __ ] that I'm
not eating another class exactly
humanities Communication Studies oh my
God all these women study if you want a
career go in the medical field or
something that can get you you know to
that next level I'm saying if you
[ __ ] learning poems and [ __ ] and you
want to bachelor eyes yourself on poems
[ __ ] man good luck I've met a lot of
Badu people need to hear that hard truth
cuz I know so many people they're like
yeah I'm gonna get like a theater degree
and like now they're mad at themselves
like literally yeah you're gonna [ __ ]
have a two hundred thousand dollar debt
with a literature degree and you can't
write for [ __ ] ah yeah you got people
over here with [ __ ] no ever like
writing [ __ ] background at all
they're selling books on Amazon it would
be different if I knew people that had
like these literature degrees or like
theater degrees they were like yes my
life is beautiful now everything is
great but like they're all mad and I'm
like damn dawg I'm real sorry about that
this is kind of interesting there's like
you'll see people like they'll graduate
with the sociology which is not a
problem but if your if your goal was
just to I don't know work for the state
which is great you know yeah like a
Social Work you didn't have to go to
[ __ ] USC for that no not I mean I
wasted a lot of money you could have
went to a state university which has
great education and you wouldn't be so
much in [ __ ] debt yep with the career
that's not gonna make you that type of
money to pay it off this is social work
hope the people right then will happen
you became a clown yep which is tell
social work without having to be sucked
into the lyrics out there do you help a
funny bone
[Laughter]
to listen to peaceably tickle put the
photo this is my funny bone is laughing
if somewhere here is honey
yeah I hope people forget
uh why don't they redo this study uh
well yeah I mean it's just that they're
publishing this everyone knows Lucy
I bet you there's more of those one
thing I've learned just kind of being
the age that I am is that twenty years
the thing is thank you it's okay you can
call me old [ __ ] I don't look like an
old [ __ ] so I'll take it
sixteen we could have ended it out of
such an empowering point I mean you love
23 specialists okay look there he goes
that's right babe you look a solid six
[Laughter]
let's just uh [ __ ] who doesn't
understand the social standard she was
just more with God maybe he means out of
a ten like ten being bombs Bob
I want to hear Jill's wisdom all the
years old
Jill's wisdom like a like she's like old
like a turtle you know like yeah like a
wonderful Chinese kung-fu master yeah
yeah okay you guys looks like that
junior high
[Laughter]
it's a kung-fu master with the elixir of
youth I'm not sharing my knowledge
anymore
oh no one thing that's a couple of
things that I've learned in my many
years of life is the first one
everyone's equally [ __ ] up as you are
like me as a person u.s. verse everyone
has [ __ ] problems everyone is [ __ ]
I mean I mean [ __ ] up alright that's
the first one the second one is there is
no actual like one way to do [ __ ] there
oh yeah one truth other than we're all
gonna die and that's about it
Wow yeah that's almost are you like
uplifting oh no it is cuz I'm just
basically saying like it's not just one
way it's not like there's no absolute
other than we're all gonna die man so
live today alright sick haha you know I
just realized poor Jesus Christ man I
don't why my t-shirt cute
[Music]
[Music]